il y a une attaque sur Mario Paul pour
le reste ce sont des bombardements alors
des attaques à base d'artillerie mais
pas avec des soldats donc l'armée russe
à l'heure actuelle elle a atteint son
apogée
elle est fixée en terme militaire et les
fixée à peu près partout elle a perdu
semble-t-il sa capacité de manœuvre en
gros et elle semble se concentrer sur
Mario Paul la seule vraie attaque c'est
Mario Paul le reste c'est du
bombardement à viser de terreur ce qui
se passe autour de Kiev l'armée russe
elle essaye quand même d'encercler
aujourd'hui la capitale
elle essaye mais je pense pas qu'elle
ait fait d'avancer significative en tout
cas pas depuis ce matin quand j'ai
regardé entre guillemets la presse j'ai
pas accès à l'information classifiée et
puis surtout elle n'a plus de capacité
de manœuvre je pense d'ailleurs que
cette armée qui assiège va bientôt se
retrouver dans le contexte difficile de
beaucoup d'armée ou c'est l'assiegent
qui devient siégé elle est au milieu
d'un nid de frelons et je pense que ça
va commencer à piquer assez dur elle
était elle n'était pas assez préparée
cette armée russe
pas assez préparé par ses compétentes et
pas assez puissante en toute hypothèse
même si elle avait été préparée et
compétente pas assez puissante pour les
objectifs qui lui ont été assignés une
attaque sur trois fronts avec les moyens
qu'ils ont égal au nom du principe qui
trop en brasse peut étreint et ben il
arrive à aucun résultat décisif nulle
part en dehors de bombarder et de casser
bien sûr alors il y a une forte
résistance aussi côté
ukrainien cette résistance elle est
permise notamment par les armes fournies
par les Occidentaux aujourd'hui les
États-Unis je le rappelle ont promis 800
millions d'aides supplémentaires à
l'Ukraine la semaine dernière avec
notamment de nouveaux lance-missiles
très clairement
déjà l'Ukraine a survécu au premier choc
les deux premiers jours grâce à des
renseignements fournis par les
Américains et peut-être les Britanniques
qui ont été de très grande qualité et
qui ont vraiment permis au moins de
sauver la mise les deux premiers jours
l'appui en renseignement a été
absolument déterminant et a permis aux
Ukrainiens de réagir ensuite les
missiles la Grande-Bretagne et les
États-Unis avaient donné pas mal de
missiles aux Ukrainiens avant la guerre
cela a été déterminant là aussi pour
leur permettre de survivre au premier
choc et maintenant il y a des quantités
importantes de missiles et de nouvelles
armes qui qui rentrent en Ukraine et qui
font que progressivement la balance du
du rapport de force
elle sait équilibre les pertes chez les
Russes sont très importantes et je pense
qu'elles vont s'accro de façon
significative alors tout de même depuis
le début la Russie a une supériorité en
armement elle dit ce week-end avoir
utilisé des missiles hypersoniques en
Ukraine c'est quoi ces missiles c'est
une manière de retrouver un élan
justement dans cette offensive qui
patine
est totalement
inutile dans ce contexte c'est
l'équivalent du V2 pour Adolf Hitler
c'est une technologie époustouflante
elle est imparable et elle ne changera
rien aux résultats de la guerre je le
perçois pour ma part comme un signe de
faiblesse des Russes c'est à dire que à
l'heure actuelle comme ils n'ont pas de
solution sur le terrain de solution
tactiques sur le terrain pour remporter
la victoire comme ils n'ont pas d'autres
solutions que de continuer à détruire le
pays il cherche à faire des des éclats
des des
c'est du feu d'artifice c'est aussi
important stratégiquement que des feux
d'artifice en l'occurrence le plus un
message adressé à l'OTAN que cause
ukrainien du point de vue de la personne
qui est dans une maison quand elle
reçoit 500 kg d'explosifs sur la tête
que ce soit venu dans un missile
hypersonique ou dans une bombe classique
ça lui est totalement équilatéral donc
en Ukraine je pense que en pratique les
gens s'en foutent le kingsal a détruit
semble-t-il la première frappe de King
Charles a détruit du carburant donc ils
ont dépensé 5 millions de dollars pour
faire brûler je sais pas quelques
centaines de mètres cubes de carburant
c'est avant tout un effet psychologique
qui est recherché en utilisant ces armes
voilà et j'attire l'attention sur
l'effet psychologique c'est plutôt vers
l'Occident et que plus vous la presse
occidentale fait l'apologie du kingjal
le kingjal est un change là donne le
kingja les quelque chose plus nous
rentrons dans le jeu de Poutine quand on
regardera le Kinja et qu'on lui dira yes
so what c'est quoi la suivante c'est un
feu d'artifice continue ton feu
d'artifice ce jour-là le Kinja perdra de
son de son importance justement jusqu'où
pourrait aller Vladimir Poutine pour
faire plier l'Ukraine on a du mal à
imaginer le président russe abandonné
son offensive est-ce qu'il pourrait
utiliser par exemple des armes chimiques
ou des armes nucléaires il a plusieurs
fois brandi cette menace en tout cas
oui et c'est inquiétant parce que en
particulier pour l'arme nucléaire la
doctrine russe qu'ils ont montré à ZAPA
de l'exercice Zappa de 2013 parle de
frappe de désescalades je ne rigole pas
je dis frappe de désescalade au sens on
tire un missile pas trop puissant pour
carboniser une ville moyenne et c'est un
message envoyé aux autres en disant
maintenant on se calme eux ont ça dans
leur dans leur doctrine il est pas exclu
que ça vienne sur sur l'Ukraine monsieur
Poutine il est réduit à une fuite en
avant son problème c'est que ça cuit en
avant c'est jusqu'au dernier de ses
soldats c'est à dire que lui est résolu
à pousser jusqu'au dernier de ses
soldats un suicide sans objet en
Ukraine
il joue son bateau monsieur Poutine il
survivra pas à cette crise